Alors évidemment bonjour à tous
il y a quelques jours, je vous ai proposé de faire cette vidéo
avec moi en me proposant des personnes que je pourrais imiter
Puisque dans ma vidéo de mardi dernier,
Philippe Roche m'apprenait à imiter les gens
Je me marre déjà du ridicule
que je vais subir
Vous avez été très nombreux à répondre
J'ai pioché quelques réponses
je propose le jeu suivant
je fais l'imitation, comme ça vous essayez de le trouver
et après je vous met la réponse en dessous
deuxième imitation :
Hey Timon, c'est juste un bébé lion !
je sens comme un vent de panique monter en moi
ha ha ! je sais pas du tout ce que ça donne
Donc c'était pumba du roi lion
Et j'ai plus de voix
Alors la prochaine imitation, elle se fait comme ça
Il faut être en couperteau, apparemment comme m'expliquait Philippe Roche
Et je ne sais pas si vous avez deviné
C'est donc Maïté
Sauf que Micka rose tu n'as pas été très sympathique puisque
Elle n'est pas décédée
Tu confonds avec Jean-Pierre Coffe
En troisième imitation, vous m'avez aussi demandé ma soeur
Vous l'avez demandé, puisqu'un jour j'ai laissé ma caméra
traîner chez elle
Au tout début des vidéos
et elle, pour me faire une blague
elle s'est filmée
donc elle se filme, pensant me faire une blague pendant que je suis sous la douche
chez elle .... Je vous laisse découvrir ces
secondes de bonheur intense
Coucou, c'est Noël une fois dans le ciel
La la la, la la la la, la la la la, la la
hey !!
Alors le gars il se dit j'ai une bonne idée bah ben sûr j'ai une bonne idée je vais essayer
je vais essayer des imitations
Salut !! A jamais du coup.... j'étais en train
de dire au revoir à ma dignité
Je ne devais plus chanter, mais je suis obligé pour l'imiter
Un homme qui avait une moustache, mais
mais j'ai plus trop de rimes en ache !!
C'était donc une excellente imitation de brassens
Pour le prochain, vous allez être obligé de trouver mais moi je fais
la ...... des années 1990
Mais vous allez peut-être me reconnaître si je fais
Adrienne !!! Adrienne !!!! C'est pas moi qui l'ai voulu cette putain
d'guerre
C'est un mélange entre rocky et rambo, c'est un ramby
la vous m'emmenez sur des trucs ..... Oh la la ma chérie, tu es
magnifique, tu es.... tu es un C
Tu es un C.... Un ç
Très rare.... C'est quoi cet accent
J'avais plus l'impression d'être marco dans tu sais le bachelor
Cette année, je sais pas si tu as vu Marco
Il parlait plus comme ça, plus que
Cristina ! Non je regarde pas le bachelor
Des fois je tombe dessus
par hasard
en replay
Et pour terminer je vous dirais juste bienvenue sur l'île de la team mentallo
Avec cette année, des défis, des épreuves
tenir pendant un an en faisant une vidéo par jour pour l'équipe
devant sa caméra
avec de l'autre côté, les abonnés, qui eux devront
liker, commenter et
regarder tous les jours, même quand
quand fabien décide de chanter ..... bah voilà
je crois que j'ai oublié personne
y a personne que vous vouliez en plus
non..... Non je refuse de... de le faire
j'ai déjà essayé de l'imiter dans une autre vidéo
Merci d'avoir participé à ce délire avec moi
ça m'a fait marrer de le faire, j'espère que ça vous a fait marrer aussi
de faire ces propositions là,
continuez de me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux et moi je continue de
vous solliciter de temps en temps pour faire des vidéos
un petit peu différentes comme ça
maintenant que ma dignité est partie
je ne risque plus rien
si vous avez souri, ne serait ce qu'une fois vous pouvez me le faire savoir en lâchant un petit
Pouce en l'air !! dépêchez vous
les schtroumpfs !! eh oui parce que j'ai
un hic, c'était le grand shctroumpf
et personne me l'a demandé
je suis très déçu de ça
et comme depuis mardi, en appliquant les conseils de philippe Roche
j'ai réussi à m'entraîner un peu
sur une nouvelle voie, je vais terminer
comme ça .... Bonjour
Si vous voulez vous pouvez aussi laisser un petit commmentaire
J'y répondrai.... bah oui qu'est ce qu'il y a
j'y répondrai ! et puis vous pouvez aussi
vous abonner avant de partir
pourquoi ? bah je vais vous le dire pourquoi
parce que le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an